hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're in
round 12 of our coverage the 2018 Tata
Steel tournament we only have 13 rounds
in the tournaments and coming into round
12 we have three players tied for first
place one of those players a nice giri
which we're gonna be looking at today
playing the white pieces and anis she
normally plays very solid chess but he
has a reputation of drawing a lot there
was some friendly banter between Anisha
and Magnus Carlsen even in this
tournament so far about an Assyrian how
he has changed quite a bit in this
tournament specifically not going for a
lot of draws like he has in the past he
hasn't lost a game he has four wins
against such a tough field so in round
12 looking to get a victory to make sure
that he is keeping pace with the other
two people tied at the top his opponents
out of Mombasa katana we looked at one
of his games in round 2 he will be
playing the black pieces not having the
tournament's he is hoping for he's
currently in second to last play so we
have a tale of two different players in
a tournament that should go down as one
of the best tournaments we've had in
quite some time just been extremely fun
to commentate hopefully you guys have
enjoyed watching it we'll start out with
nice Yuri he plays pawn to c4 and right
out the gate we see an unusual move with
pawn to g6 not the way we usually see
black defend against the English opening
but you know this is one of those
openings where certain players have
things that they've been working on in
the lab before they come to these big
tournaments and they want to see what
they can do especially if you're second
to last in tournament if you didn't
think it was a good time because you
didn't think it was maybe quite solid
enough or you just want to try something
out try something out I don't think you
have anything to lose so g6 is the move
from audubon then we see pawn d4 just
trying to build up in the center of the
board Bishop to g7 think at
on the kingside knight to f3 pawn c5
trying to break up the center pawn d5
and then pawn here to d6
white continues to push forward in the
center of the board plays pawn to e4 and
then we see pawn east six not really
interested in exchange of material right
now Bishop to d3 getting ready to castle
on the kingside would you see an
exchange on board and then Bishop down
here to g4 just trying to get his pieces
developed into the board
he has other options Knight f6 I think
makes a lot of sense even if you want to
play Knight to a6 he's not going to be
playing Knight to c6 I do think he wants
to get his life squared Bishop involved
into the game before it plays Knight to
d7 blocking that since there's not the e
pawn it doesn't block the lights for a
bishop so he's going to be getting the Y
squared Bishop involved at some point
doesn't have to do it right now could
also just be playing Queen to e7 pinning
down this pawn to the King right here so
you know this is just another option
that Bach has the bishop can't move
because it is the only piece right now
but finding this pawn but decides to go
ahead and get his life square Bishop out
first Bishop here to a g4 9 now plays to
d2 Knight to f6 then we see both sides
castle 2 at the King side pawn to h3
pushing at the Bishop back but we see
black decided to go ahead and exchange
on board this does give a nice shiri the
double bishops on board definitely a
strong advantage in my opinion
especially if you can open up the board
States which is gonna be pretty easy to
do you just push the pawn start to
exchange and then the bishop hairs gonna
be extremely valuable for whites there's
a couple ways that black kick continued
here he decides to play pawn to seaboard
it looks a little weird just right away
so and we're just giving that pawn to
White's yes but also keep in mind this
night here on f6 is attacking the pawn
on e4 and the bishop is the only piece
that's defending it so as soon as the
bishop takes here on c4 then I could
come down take here on e4 and that's
what happened in the game there were
some other options you could have seen
black play
to e8 attacking this pond now we have
both the Knights and at the rook
attacking it you could see rook to e1
defending that and then just completely
avoiding trying to play pawn to c4 and
just getting that pawn off the board
maybe he wants to push a little further
down the board with pawn to a6 and then
pawn to b5 try to get a queen advantage
with his pawns and then Knight to d7
here so has some options besides that
things that he was looking at on board
but in the end he decided to go ahead
and play pawn to c4 and after the Bishop
takes Knight takes here on e4 both sides
also have an isolated pawn on the D file
white does have his pawn further up the
board on this fifth rank right here
black would really like a pond to
protect this night here on e4 it's gonna
be very easy for white to attack this
Knight to put pressure on it and since
it's not being defended by a pawn is
going to have to retreat at some point
rook to e1 trying to kick it back hook
to e8 defending the knight for right now
Queen to c2 says yeah I now have more
material attacking that and so the
Knights forced to come back here to f6
rook up here takes on eh the sides to
take with this Knight could also take
with this Queen that's also a viable
option but decides to take with his
night here on e8 bishop up here to g5
attacking the Queen and the knight
coming back here to f6 Knight to d4 just
centralizing the knight here usually
gonna be on f3 to control some of the
central squares many times white will
have a pawn here on a d4 sometimes if he
pushed a little further here to e5 as
well but since both white does not have
pawns here and black is not really
attacking or setting up something around
of these squares then why it's able to
push a little bit further up the board
and play Knight to d4 also just a good
central square for this night to control
a lot of squares on board if either
these pawns upon b7 or f7 were to ever
move there's a great outpost depending
on where black's pieces are
that's hon Queen down here to b6 and
this kind of shaniyah where does black
decide to go here right now he plays
Queen to b6 I think it makes a lot of
sense to get his knight involved into
the game there's really only one option
that's Knight to d7 his LightSquared
Bishop is already developed it's off the
board by this point this does allow the
knight to easily come to e5 or c5 for an
outpost but in the game he plays Queen
to b6 not quite sure this is the best
move though it is attacking and the
night here on d4 so white is forced to
defend it brings his bishop back here to
e3 and then Knight down here to g4 and
this is where things get interesting
because you may look at and say okay
that's just giving up the knight but is
a discovered attack that Bishop is now
attacking the knight both the Queen and
the bishop are attacking this so if we
see the pawn take here on a g4 then
we're just going to see an exchange
Bishop takes on d4 and then if we want
to see the bishop take the Queen's gonna
recapture have a very very aggressive
square here from the Queen or Y could
just say I'm not too worried about
taking that Bishop I can play rook to e1
that makes a lot of sense as well so
there are some options on board after
the Knight to g4 this yuria now plays
Queen to e4 which is someone interesting
it in the next move I I think is a
little bit odd because I do think that
the Knight to g4 was a good move it I
don't know that the nature II was
expecting the knight to come down here
and so from here I would say how can
block improve the position and I think
exchange of material here getting that
Bishop pair off the board would be very
very valuable you can now see queen up
here to EA check bishop to f8 really the
only move now the pawn takes and I still
think black is in a good position here
Queen up here to c7 no other real option
if we start to say you know where were
the knight go to well if the knight
moves then the rooks going to follow the
bishop can't move it's pinned down by
the Queen to the King here so Queens who
c7 makes a lot of sense it's both
defending as well as attacking this
bishop here on c4
Lexx pot here but in the game once we
see Queens Hui for blacks more in a just
retrieved defense mode
plays Knights back to f6 and then Queen
to e7 you start to see white putting a
lot of pressure on black his position is
cramped he still has not got his nights
here on b8 involved into the action all
which means the rook here on e8 is not
involved at all and just really has a
cramped position not real clear how
black is really going to get out of this
and have any sort of attack because
white doesn't have to worry about black
too much right now black now plays
Knight to d7 so finally get involved
into the action not up here to b5 adding
pressure to this pawn on d6 both the
Queen and the knight now attacking it
Bishop up here to f8 says okay if you
are going to attack my pawn also have a
discovered attack if you didn't notice
the knight coming here to b5 also has a
discovered attack with the bishop here
on e3 attack in the Queen says if you're
gonna do that I really need to have a
strong counter-attack and that's going
to be Bishop here to f8
not only does it attack the Queen but it
also if the Queen were to move would
defend the square here on d6 which white
is attacking
so why decides a let's go ahead and
exchange material off the board but good
news for white the night here on a b5
also attacks the square here on a7 and
why it is able to go up a pawn in
material so white now has a clear
advantage in the game both from just a
developmental standpoint as well as a
material advantage as well Knight down
here to e5 pawn to AB III just
solidifying getting some added
protection to this Knight and then we
see the knight exchange so both sides
even on the minor pieces pawn recaptures
on c4 and then rook over here to c8
attacking this pawn now a few ways that
white can respond it's fair to just play
rook to c1 and defend it right away
and these shiri decides to play a little
different play rook to e1 attacking the
bishop the bishops now forced to move to
f8 which is a better square for white
and so now Bishop to d4 attacking the
knight the night comes back here to d7
and now the rook is gonna come over here
to c1 so anytime you find a good move it
makes sense to bring your rook here to
c1 see if there's some in between moves
you can force your opponent to play
certain places so that you can get to c1
and have your opponent in a worse
position than he was before now rook to
e8 attacking the pawn here on a2 very
easy for a nice year to just play rook
to c2 defending that pawn rook down here
to a6
rook over here to e 2 getting ready to
just push up here to e8 that is a very
strong attack that black has to worry
about and rook down here to a4 rook up
to e8 as we talked about rook takes on a
c4 why it's not too worried about that
it plays rook to d8 he has a few options
here one of his options is to get his
bishop involved bishop here to f6 and
then here to e7 that is going to attack
this pin down piece here on f8 and he
recognizes that now he's starting to put
too much pressure on blacks Knights here
on D 7 as well as this pawn at the
knight moves both the night and at the
rook here it's hacking the square here
on d6 so he is able to get that pawn
back if he wants to that he gave up on
c4 very difficult right now as far as
how black continues he decides to go
ahead and play Knight to e5 he could
have counter attacked and played rook to
b4 I think he's still in a tough
position
but rook to b4 does give some promise
hey if you want to take my my Knights I
will go ahead and take your knight as
well decide to go and play Knight to e5
and then pawn to f4 and this is this is
a really difficult position I feel like
black the entire game has been put in
these really difficult positions as far
as how do I move my pieces in a way
that I'm not just getting attacked the
entire game cuz white has had his way
with black so far in this game and from
here he decides okay my knight doesn't
have a good square because if it comes
back here to d7 it's gonna be captured
okay well where as does it go to the
only real safe square would be Knight to
d3 now could also as we talked about
bring the rook over here to b5 try to
defend something that's not the the
greatest could instead play rook to c1
this makes more sense than now trying to
play rook to b4 I think that train has
left the station no longer good move
rook to c1 trying to attack the opponent
King to h2 and now Knight to c4 this
square is now opened up and the rook is
defending so that's probably the best
option that black has he played that
night to d3 the the real safe square for
the knight but really just allows white
to have a strong attack that bishop here
to f6 is we talked about preparing for
the move Bishop here to e7 rook to e4 so
this does stop this slightly if we were
to see the rook take on f4
okay well then Bishop to e7 you can see
how things go poorly from here rook up
to f5 Knight takes on d6 both attacking
the rook and gobbling up material if the
rook were to take on d5 then rook over
here f8 check after the King moves then
we just see things go very very poorly
for black and at the end of the day this
is going to be an easy in game for white
so after Bishop to f6 we see rook to e4
just blocking the bishop coming here to
e7 another option that white has is to
bring his bishop here to g5 and then
swing it back to h6 a little more
difficult for black to deal with that it
does the same thing it's hacking this
pinned piece down or attacking the pin
piece here on f8 a nice giri continues
knight takes on d6
attacking the rook rook comes down here
to e1 check king h2 and then night 2 f2
this is opening up the door for rook to
h1 but that's just a check the King can
easily come here to g3 now we see Bishop
to g5 since onigiri knows his bishops
not gonna come to a 7 because of the
rook decides to go for Plan B and that
is to get the bishop here to h6 we see
black play pawn to h5 hoping for a
miracle of the pawn at some point
getting to h4 not being attacked it
would be attacked right away with the
bishop here and then you know maybe
there's an off chance that there's a
surprise checkmate with rook to h1 but
White's not gonna fall for that first
place Bishop here to h6 knowing that he
has a couple moves it would have to be
first pawn moves and then the rook over
here black does not have enough time for
that we see first pawn up here to g4
this does open up some air for the King
to move and so we could see the King
come here to h7 and you could say okay
what happens if instead of that we see
you know maybe the the pawn takes with
on passant
okay well from here we just see the King
take on g3 this is one option that up
here to e4 check the knight takes okay
this is all going to end very poorly
after the bishop takes here on f8 so if
we come back King to h7 rook over here
taking that bishop and the knight to d3
and the King can't really take the
bishop as well it looks like it's
hanging
but really it's gonna be very difficult
for black to deal with that as well and
that rook takes the pawn here on f7
maybe there's a check that's fine cannot
continue to check and then after the
knight false then you're good just gonna
see the night come involved over here
for White's perspective and at the end
of day white is going to win this game
so while it may look like yes the King
is just going to take it is not in well
for black although Knight to d3 doesn't
really help too much on board rook takes
on F
seven King back here to age 8 and then
rook to f8 and at this point we do see a
resignation from Audubon and I think at
the end of the day he was just
outclassed I think he was trying
something novel with pawn to g6 at the
beginning and east you received a very
prepared for that
and at the end of the day just puts out
of on Abbas got on in too many tough
positions and completely controlled the
game and that's what he's been doing so
far in the tournament you don't go
through 12 rounds have five victories
now and have no losses without being
very very prepared and locked in what's
your what your game plan is so
congratulations to him good news is he
won bad news is Magnus Carlsen won as
well so it's now a two-person tie for
first now both of those players have to
be aware that there's a lot of players
behind them ready to strike as well
there's five players going into the last
round that can actually win this
tournament which is crazy to think about
many times getting last round one
players either wrapped it up or it's a
two-person race we have five players
that can actually win this so a lot of
people in second place hoping for some
draws or some losses for an h3 and
Magnus Carlsen tomorrow it will be
fireworks and we will have coverage so
thank you guys for watching
round 12 hope you enjoyed it and I will
see you in the final round